What,
what was it that when you first got brought into a mental hospital,
what was it about?
Well,
I had got hit by a car and the,
uh,
the hood ornament went in my head in my brains and scramble them and I,
I used to be an a plus math student.
I was just great in geometry.
Oh my God.
I loved geometry.
I got straight A's and then,
you know,
I sort of fell apart after that.
Took a long time to heal from it.
And um,
you know,
uh,
how much did your personality change?
Oh,
it changed drastically.
But you know,
you read all that stuff about a traumatic head injuries now cause I do read a
lot and talk to a lot of football players who have the same thing and we do
discuss it.
Yeah,
you changed right away.
Yeah.
It's still you,
but it's like a,
it's kind of like an Artel artificial intelligence.
You Do,
you find that,
did you find that you became much more impulsive?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
Here's what happened.
I was crossing the street on my way to school.
How old were you?
Have a 16.
No,
it's 15.
Go on the first week of high school.
And,
uh,
how's a big nerd?
And Anyway,
uh,
was crossing the street and then it was a top of the hill.
And this woman girl,
she was on her way of the university and the sun blinded her and she ran me
over.
And,
uh,
the rest is history.
How long were you in the hospital for?
Mm,
so first you must,
you must have been in a medical hospital first,
and then you were miss admitted to a mental hospital after was about three
months in between.
Right.
Uh,
but I was in the hospital for a while,
you know,
and,
uh,
I had a head concussion and a brain concussion and I had hamburger meat for
legs.
So they did all these,
um,
what do they call them?
Skin grafts on my legs.
Uh,
and,
um,
yeah,
I was in there for a while,
then I came out of there and I had forgotten everything about math when I
returned to school.
We're s matter of weeks after that,
maybe two months.
I'm really bad on time now,
but uh,
and uh,
I had forgotten all my math and it was just terrible.
That was a big depressive depression I went into because I couldn't remember.
I couldn't remember things,
you know?
And also I became way more impulsive then I was like,
I don't know what I did.
Then I started going really
out there into the ethers.
I went way out there.
Okay.
How so?
Why out?
You know how you go way out?
You have to go way out.
No,
I'm really,
I've had a lot of head injuries.
Oh yeah.
I've been at but not terrible.
Mostly just punches and kicks.
Nothin like car accidents or never played football.
Yeah.
But my head injuries of,
you know,
there were just more a cumulative when I was young till I was about 21,
22 where I stopped,
stop fighting,
stop sparring.
Yeah.
But nothing but a,
definitely I'm subject to impulsive behavior still.
Yeah.
But I can't keep it under wraps.
I keep it under control because I'm aware of it.
But when I was younger,
I didn't understand what was going on.
I would just be subject to whims,
very addictive behavior,
but I've tried to keep it positive,
but it would be addicted to things,
addicted to doing things,
addicted to games,
addicted like ridiculously addictive.
I spend 10 1214 hours a day playing video games.
That kind of shit.
My Kid.
Yeah,
well some of it's just normal because video games are awesome.
But yeah,
it would be for me to be everything,
martial arts,
pool,
whatever do is I'll just be completely obsessed with it and to be thinking about
it all day in port where it wasn't necessarily healthy and just on a whim I
would just want to go do something.
I just,
I almost had no control over compulsion's you know?
And I think some of that is whatever brain injuries that I've had are very mild
in comparison to a lot of people that I know,
certainly very mild in comparison to yours.
And now is a lot of trauma in the state hospital that,
you know,
I'm like,
being there and seeing and experiencing.
And how long did that for nine months.
So what was it that they brought you in there for?
What was,
how were you behaving that they decided that you needed to be admitted?
I was out there.
You say that,
like what does that mean?
MMM.
I don't think there's any words.
The English you just can't understand.
Didn't have a control of reality.
You didn't have control of your behavior.
Your thinking was screwed up.
I was,
you know,
not thinking like the normal thing that they say you should be thinking about
and,
but people round you had realized it,
that it was,
it was so bad that they had to admit you to a hospital wasn't just a over
Rosanne.
She's eccentric.
It was,
she needs actual medical help.
Yeah.
I asked to be admitted.
Do you knew something was really wrong?
Yeah.
Hi Sean.
They admitted it was,
did you know at the time where you completely aware that it was connected to
your car accident?
Uh,
no.
You just knew something was wrong.
Yeah.
And back then they didn't really kind of understand that the way they understand
it now.
No,
they
didn't understand too much about bipolar disorder or they knew nothing about,
um,
multiple personality disorder.
Trauma related trauma related.
Yeah.
PTSD.
Now they call everything pts and they don't even say d anymore.
They say pts
post traumatic stress.
So when they admitted you,
what was the treatment like?
What did they do to you when you were inside the mental hospital?
Well,
they right away put me on an antipsychotic.
What was it?
Do you remember Mallory Rail and what did that do?
I don't know.
I wasn't there.
I was gone.
I was just watching these people.
I was in the mental institution with,
and I wanted to tell that story because there was this one lady,
I think I told this to Paul Reubens too.
I think it might be where he got large Marge.
But there's this one lady and she's in this cage,
you know,
she's in a cage with keys on our ward there.
And uh,
uh,
Christ,
I can't remember her name either.
Marge,
her name was march.
Yeah.
And she's about 600,
700 pounds.
And she's funnier than hell.
You know,
I thought,
man,
this,
this chick's got smooth lines,
you know,
and I traded lines with her and she'd laugh.
You know,
you,
you know,
I was like jokes,
you can always find a joke wherever you are,
you know,
that's the key to life I think.
But,
um,
okay,
so sh oh,
everybody called me chunky.
That was my name,
chunky.
And uh,
there was another girl in their name,
shorty,
so it was chunky and shorty we were like a duo.
But anyway,
um,
so she's like,
hey,
Roseanne,
get what's her name's keys when they go to dinner and open this up here,
you know,
come in here.
I'm like,
okay.
You know,
cause,
you know,
after all I was crazy too.
And uh,
and I trust,
I don't know,
I just always,
I never questioned that there was danger anywhere.
I always got in trouble,
you know,
caught,
beat up something,
you know.
But,
uh,
so I did it,
you know,
and I can't all Onca that was her name,
the head nurse.
I hated her because she told me I needed a base.
I'll tell that story later.
It was horrifying.
It changed my life.
But anyway,
so they all go to dinner.
So I go in there,
steal the case out of the thing where they are,
you know the attendance and I go in there with Marge and
leave the keys in the door and close the door.
Yeah.
So I'm like,
hey Margie or doe,
how's it going?
Margin.
And she's like Chunky.
You know why they put me in this cage?
Don't you
take some drag of a cigarette?
I go,
well,
why?
No,
I don't know why.
Well chunky
because they consider me to be dangerous.
I'm Mike,
how calm
I am.
I'm like Gomer Pyle,
right?
Seriously.
And I'm total gold and you're like 16 at the time.
about eight minutes into it I realized,
Oh shit.
Oh Shit,
something's going on here.
That's how long it always took me to like zero in on what's happening.
Cause I'm not even there.
You know?
I'm always ignoring when other people talk.
I don't listen.
I'm thinking of funny things that they bore me,
you know?
Yeah.
So I'm always in my own head.
I never get out really except for when I work.
But,
uh,
so,
then it got,
then it took a turn in or she's like,
so it got to a,
why do they consider you dangerous?
You know,
I had to ask it cause she kept on getting me there to that point where she
wanted me to ask it.
I was trying to delay it and you know,
cause I knew they'd be back in 40 minutes and it was like going on 20 now
she goes,
I'm in here because that's my voice I got to do with Margaret.
I'm in here because
I broke a couple of tenants bags and they tell you that.
No,
my ha,
how'd you do that?
And in my head I'm thinking,
don't change.
Don't miss a beat.
Don't miss a breath.
Don't look nowhere,
just to keep on Ecmo.
You know,
Utah,
your dog girl.
Cause she knew she was dangerous.
Well that's when it hit my head that it was,
oh,
she's talking about,
you know,
I'm uh,
I'm feeling like pray.
Right.
You know,
and uh,
I go,
how'd you do that?
Cause I'd figured,
Oh,
it's an accident.
You know,
it's good.
All Marge,
she sales,
good job.
She goes,
well,
it's easy.
You just know I'm doing me again.
I got to do her.
It's easy.
You just put one hand here and one hand here and then you're
like,
oh,
ah
hmm.
Where'd you learn that?
I don't.
I'm changing the subject and a hundred.
How was your mom?
What was the school like?
You went to,
what's your favorite book?
What's your favorite color?
What kind of ice cream you like?
You ever seen that there's worms in the oatmeal?
You ever noticed that
she started?
Got that one.
Got Her.
She's like,
yeah,
I did.
I did notice I would crawl and motherfuckers I go,
yeah,
next week does to eat that,
this shoe,
this one.
You know,
I,
I like suddenly I'm transported to a confederacy of dunces when he's on the
thing against Levi pants.
Remember that rant in that book?
So I'm just tap dancing really.
And uh,
then I hear it click,
man.
I grabbed,
I got up,
fumbled the keys out of the door,
put them back in the,
uh,
attendance room.
What?
My Room
when you said you hear it click.
Yeah,
I knew the first door got opened.
There was two doors that I heard the first door open.
They're coming back from,
from dinner.
So you got away from us,
be sick,
you know,
in my room.
Right.
That's why I didn't go to dinner.
Yeah.
So I'm just laying there and that was like daily.
I mean there were so many weird people in there.
We had this one girl,
Rosie,
her name was where she'd always grabbed.
She always ended up with a pair of real sharp scissors and lunch for someone's
throat.
We're like,
where'd you get them?
Who's bringing her them scissors,
you know?
But anyway,
I went on antipsychotic medicine and um,
that was good that I was on there for the Shit I saw.
Now when you say anything,
my friends hanging and stuff like that.
I'm sorry.
Friends hanging out in the mental institution.
Yeah.
So I saw worse than that.
What'd you say?
Hi.
I saw,
you know,
victims of abuse was terrible by the guards.
Know if kids come in,
you know,
victims of abuse families that came in that were mentally scarred by it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Now when they put you on anti psychotics,
was it because you were exhibiting psychotic behavior?
What,
what,
what kind of psychotic behavior?
While they thought it was psychotic,
I was just scared that they are.
I think I was throwing them off cause I want him to think I was psychotic.
I didn't want to think them to think I was schizophrenia.
I knew enough not to let them near me.
They,
if,
cause once you got the,
uh,
once you got the diagnosis of schizophrenia,
they would no shocks and they'd experiment on your,
basically you're in Guinea pig and I didn't want that.
So maybe I,
you know,
and then,
so yeah,
I was doing weird things like walking down the middle of streets after I buy the
car,
I walked down the middle of streets.
I don't know,
I thought,
oh you got to get over your fear of crossing the streets.
That's what was in my head.
And then I'd walk down the highway,
you know,
I was in a whole other realm.
It was like a real surrealistic and metaphysical realm.
And I grew comfortable there.
But you know,
I think most artists,
writers,
and performers are in that world.
I mean,
we got a toe in it,
at least.